skype zoom ou encore google mythe les
associations yvelinoise se sont mises à
la visioconférence
un outil qui leur permet de maintenir
une activité pendant ce deuxième
confinement pour le rugby club de
versailles les cours en visio se
concentre sur la préparation physique on
est en général entre 40 et 50
donc les mecs viennent à 19h sur le sur
le zoom on utilise zoom comme comme
appli et puis et puis après je leur
donne tout ce qu'ils ont à faire
je leur explique ça ça dure entre 45
minutes et une heure et puis les mecs
les mecs en bavent peut quoi côté
culture la compagnie du 7 septembre elle
aussi a choisi ce format au programme
rencontres répétition et exercices de
diction
là par exemple ils se sont aussi
déconnecté tous ils se sont téléphonés
par bin et ils ont écrit des petits
textes ensemble après il se reconnaît et
je lui mets à la caméra deux par deux et
10 leur texte après je leur propose des
intentions de jeu
il les joue pas donc voilà ça ça peut
être un exercice
une autre manière de travailler plus axé
sur la préparation et la technique
un format qui permet d'organiser la
reprise mais qui ne remplacent pas les
séances en présentiel
le théâtre c'est quand même un art qui
est vivant donc forcément c'est un peu
bizarre mais ça se passe plutôt bien
parce qu'on puisse qu'on travaille
vraiment des exercices et qu'on
approfondit beaucoup en fait on a
vraiment l'impression de faire un vrai
cours de théâtre
rien ne remplacera jamais le ballon
c'est bien pour l'entraînement
l'entraînement collectif au jeu de rugby
mais ça maintient les ça maintient les
joueurs en condition physique de manière
à préparer la reprise qu'on espère la
plus rapide possible
et puis ça on va dire que ça contribue
quand même malgré tout au bien être
pendant le confinement selon les
annonces gouvernementales ce mardi 24
novembre
les activités pourrait reprendre pour
tous courant janvier